the summer edition of games done quick  has just concluded after spanning 160  hours the seven-day charity speedrunning  event was jam-packed full of or  inspiring feats which you can check out  in replay form on the games done quick  youtube channel this year the event  raised one point 29 million dollars for  the humanitarian organization Doctors  Without Borders that figure bastard last  year's 1.2 million setting a new sgdq  record this year's event included all  sorts of runs including a glitch run of  Ocarina of Time a 20-minute playthrough  of the witness and a runner fallout 4  completed in just over an hour the event  wrapped up with a four player speedrun  race of super mario 64 if you can't get  enough speed running awesome games done  quick will arrive on January eighth of  next year to make you feel inadequate  all over again congratulations to all of  the talented runners and those of you  who decided to throw some dollars their  way  I